- Hello
- What up, Candace, what’s goin’ on?
- Yo, whassup, Melo?
- I got somebody you should meet.
Her name is Brehanna Daniels.
She's a tire-changer in NASCAR.
- Oh, for real?
- She used to play basketball.
She's a huge fan of yours.
I think it'd be great if you can, you know, do a little surprise for her.
- Yeah, I'm in. Of course.
and then we go from there.
♪♪♪
Brehanna Daniels: A lifetime hooper
she played her way through high school
and junior college.
Walked on at Norfolk State
with a full ride.
She lost her mother to breast cancer
but instead of tearing her down
it pushed her forward.
Now she's out here on the track.
Crossed over from the court
she's already made NASCAR history in the pit
and isn't done yet.
She's black.
She's female.
She's puttin' in work.
- Coach Horton's definitely, like, how my basketball coaches were.
Like, he's hard on me too.
Even though at first, he was, like
he said, "You know, I thought you was bulls--t"
He said, "Then when I brought you in here
I saw you. You really wanted to do this."
And I was, like, "Yeah, I really did."
- Brehanna made history by becoming the first—
- Female African American—
- Pit crew member.
- She's 24 years old.
- Front and center.
- Changing more than just tires.
- Good job. That's a good one.
- That's a good one. Good one, guys.
- I didn't know anything about NASCAR.
I'm sittin' here, lookin' like
"People really enjoy drivin' in circles
like, for a living, and they're goin' too fast."
Like, I would never.
Dang, these are throwbacks!
She taught me how to play basketball. You know that, right?
How I got my start.
You know Mom and Dad didn't play basketball.
- How you been, then?
- I've been good. I mean, just livin' the race life.
- Livin' the race life?
- How does that sound?
- The race life? It sounds crazy.
- [Laughing] Right.
- It's different.
- It is. Way different from basketball.
[Laughing]
- And when you first told me, I looked at you
like you were crazy, so—
- Exactly. I mean...
- I met Brehanna when we went on a recruiting trip
to Norfolk State University.
We're always lookin' for big, strong
male football players. In she comes.
- So I walked in the gym. I saw all these
guys, these big football players. I was
the only girl that tried out, and I could feel
people, like, sayin' how women really don't make
it like that in this sport. And I was like
"Dude, why are you telling me this?"
Cuz that's not gonna stop me from performing
the way that I do, you know?
- When I first got into the sport, I was
coaching, training, working with mechanics.
They know all about the tools of the trade.
But one of the things that they couldn't adjust
to was to perform under pressure.
The athletes know how to perform, and it's
just a situation where we had to teach them
now how to use the tools and how to make all
that work to have a fast pit stop.
You know, they come in, and they don't know
anything about it.
- The first time I went over the wall was
the weekend in Dover when I, like, made history.
I had two races back-to-back.
One of those races when I, like, jumped over
the wall too soon, the official came over and
was like, "Yeah, we had an, uh, early jump."
And I was like, "Dang, so he can't drive?"
And he was like, "No, he has to sit here
for, like, a lap or two."
I'm like, "Oh my God, dude, I'm so sorry."
He's sittin' there like—
That was a very interesting day.
You know, just, people not used to seeing a
brown girl like myself just walkin' around the track.
I could feel people, like, break their necks
like when I walk by, or they have shades on, and
they act like they're not lookin', but some people
I guess they think their tint is dark enough, but
I could see their eyes like, "What the—"
I could see their eyes like, "What the——"
You know what I'm sayin'?
This dude just tried me, like, staring at my
credentials, makin' sure I belong at this track.
Oh, I belong here.
I got, like, a real nasty look one day.
I'm like, "Hey, how ya doin' today?"
And the guy looked at me and was like—
And I'm like, "Well, dang."
So I just walked away. I'm like, "OK, well
that's somebody who's stuck in their old ways."
I remember seeing a couple tweets
"Why would she wanna join a racist sport?"
And I'm like, "What?"
But...
- Brehanna won't say it, but let's be real.
Race car teams are still dominated by white men.
And on race day, the crowd still looks like this.
But Brehanna Daniels is livin' that race life
a strong black woman forcing this old-school sport forward.
- Left arm behind your back.
Ready, stretch, one.
In the beginning, all eyes were on me.
You know, being in my position, it's not easy at all.
My mom is—she's the reason why I go so hard and
that's where a lot of my motivation comes from.
You know, just seeing her battle with, uh, breast cancer
and just—sorry.
Just seeing her battle with breast cancer most of her
life, she just taught me to be strong as a person.
You know, seeing her go through something like that, and
still she goes to basketball games, football games.
She was there cheerin' us on.
She was Wonder Woman, Superwoman, you know?
So, like, whenever I feel like giving up in anything
in life, like, I always think about her.
That plays a huge part in me being able to deal with
the stuff that I've been dealing with, you know?
before I did my first race in February, I got a call, like, um
"Brehanna, is everything all right? Because I've been
getting phone calls from people saying that they've been
lookin' at your tweets, and they're just worried about you."
And I'm like, "Dang, like, people are really lookin' at my
I said it's hard being a black woman in this sport.
And I was like, "Wow."
That's, like, the moment I realized people were
actually paying attention to my stuff.
So...
- Three years from now, hopefully we can talk about
her being on the Cup level.
But that is gonna take a lot of hard work on her part.
She has a long way to go.
- I still have more barriers and doors to break down.
Gotta get my first win.
Hopefully we will have more diversity and more
minorities in the sport.
To see my face in, like, a kid's textbook—if they can
read about something and they're like, "Hey, Mommy
there's this, uh, this girl. She made history, you know
as the first African American female tire-changer.
I wanna be like her when I grow up!"
You know, and just spark that in their mind.
I know when, like, another black female joins NASCAR
I could just take her under my wing, you know, give
her the rundown of it all.
I'm like, "Look, girl, you gotta be yourself in this sport."
[Laughing]
"Can't take nothin' from nobody. Just be yourself
come in here, work hard, do what you gotta do."
That would be a day to see right there, yes.
- We're clear all the way around?
- Yes.
- All right, thank you.
- That was a great question.
My first experience on a track would have been a bad one.
Hey, you guys need help changing a tire?
- Oh my God!
- [Laughing]
What's up?
- I love her!
- What's up, guys?
- Candace!
- Hey!
- How you doin'?
- Good.
- Good, nice to meet you.
- Why is my favorite WNBA player here?!
- How you guys doin'? You doin' all right?
This is awesome. This is my first time on a—
- Can I hug you one more time?
- Of course.
- Oh my goshhh.
OK, y'all, I'm fangirlin' right now.
This is crazy. Teaching my favorite basketball player
how to change tires, man!
- I know, really tryin' to play me today.
- Let's go, Candace!
So we usually start on this side.
- All right.
- As the car is running out, we're jumping off the wall and
running in front of the car.
- All right.
- Drop down, you know, blow—[loud whirring]
- Oh, s--t.
- That's loud, right?
You run it and you—
- All right.
- One, two, three, four—
- Missed that one.
- You're good, come on.
- I missed that one.
- It took me a long time to get it too.
Two, three, four, five.
- She's gonna show you how to take 'em off.
- OK.
Yeah, you're gonna just do that, right?
- Nah, you're gonna do it!
- Oh, man.
- Let's do it!
Yes!
- I'm definitely gettin' a penalty.
Ahhh!
- Ready? Go.
[Laughing]
- Can't stop, can't stop.
You got it, come on.
- Yes, but this one didn't come off!
- You gotta keep goin'.
- You gotta hit it, yeah.
- Yay!
[Applause]
- All right.
- Gimme some.
- Got it?
- Yeah.
- But you're running?
- Yeah, running.
- Pfft.
[Laughing]
- Set it down, yeah.
- And then you're here. Wow.
- So here's what we'll do.
We'll let you do that. You'll set that tire down and
then take those five off like you just did.
- Wow, puttin' it all together, Candace. Let's do it!
Yes!
- So go?
- Yeah.
Ready?
Oh, shoot! Yes, drop that. Oooh.
- There you go, good job.
- You got it, you got it. Go on!
- You wanna hit that harder.
- Good job, good job.
Yes, you did it.
- I failed. It's OK, though.
It's OK.
In basketball, I mean, we have our own league that's carved out
and we've been playing for 22 years.
- Yeah.
- And I think we're still trying to gain respect.
If you could say anything to the casual fan that's watching
NASCAR that's like, "Man, women can't change tires—"
- Yeah.
- Like, what would you say?
- Just give everybody, you know, the fair chance to prove themselves.
- Mhm.
- You can't just go in there judging someone cuz they're male or female.
- Yep.
I have learned so much today. It has been an honor.
You've been an inspiration.
- I'm still at a loss for words that I'm sittin' here with my idol.
- Aw, I appreciate it.
- Oh, can I—?
- Yes, of course.
- Bring it in.
- Of course. So nice seein' you, man.
- So nice meeting you, yes.
- Women constantly have to prove that you deserve to be there
but once you get that respect, and, you know, people acknowledge
that you're not just there as, like, a "token" and they
realize you're good, she'll set the bar and other women will follow.
And, you know, open up the doors for things that women didn't
have a place for years ago.
- This is Carmelo Anthony. Thanks for watching.
To meet more heroes, go to BReal.BleacherReport.com.